[Music]  listen to him I need you to do as I tell  you I need to get you on the boy away  from here  [Music]  did you see everything you needed to see  I saw enough why is the water dropped  why does the sword reveal itself now as  your power increases so too do the  forces that will oppose you  the born king will come he felt it  the Panama  I've never had any power or any desire  to achieve it that's all the fuss is  about don't worry you're soon understand  what all the fuss is about  are you scared I think I can manage you  should be scared  whoever it takes to hunt em down  Fraenkel town follow him the pig goes  down you follow me you want him to think  big give you something people think  about  [Music]  you wanted to preface it this is your  proxy the man who put sword from stone  behold  [Music]  but thanks then being allowed to care of  their business  [Music]  hold a folder backups